وقع وزيران دفاع الروسي والبيلاروسيه
اتفاقا على نشر الصواريخ نوويه روسيه
تكتيكيه في بيلاروسيا في هذه الاثناء وقال
وزير الدفاع الروسي ان الخطوه اتخذ
ت على حدود بلاده الغربيه مبتهما الغرب
بشن حرب غير معلنه ضد روسيا وبيلاروسيا
نواجه اليوم بشكل مشترك الغرب الجماعي
الذي يشن عمليا حربا غير معلنه على بلدنا
نشاط النيتو العسكري قرب حدودنا ياخذ
طابعا عدوانيا وفي ظروف تزايد التهديدات
النوويه من جانب النيتو طررنا لاتخاذ
اجراءات مضاده في المجال النووي وبناء على
قرار قاده بلدينا نظمنا عمليه نشر اسلحه
نوويه روسيه غير استراتيجيه على اراضي
بيلاروسيا لاوكرانيا بالهجوم على منشات
نوويه
روسيه وزراء الدفاع البلاروسي والروسيه
وقعان اتفاقا على نشر صواريخ تكتيكيه
نوويه في الاراضي البيلاروسيه
صحيحه عثمان هذه الخطوه التي اعلن عنها
اليوم في مينسك في الحقيقه تم التوصل
اليها بين الرئيسين الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
ونظيره البيلاروسيا الكسندر لوكاشينكو قبل
اشهر بطلب من بيلاروسيا في اطار ما يعرف
بدوله الاتحاد
للامن المشترك بين البلدين تخللتها تخللها
عدد كبير من المناورات العسكريه كما نذكر
والتدريبات سواء على الاراضي الروسيه او
على الاراضي البيلاروسيه لكن الجديد اليوم
هو ان روسيا بحسب وزير الدفاع سيشيكو
وايضا بيلاروسيا اتخذت هذه الخطوه كردد
على تحركات النيتو اولا في الحدود الغربيه
للبلدين اضافه الى ما كان الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين في مارس اذار الماضي قد
اعلن عنه بان موسكو ستتخذ اجراءات ردا على
تزويد اوكرانيا
اليورانيوم المنظم قذائف تضم او تحوي هذه
المواد
وروسيا اليوم تقول بان هذه الخطوه هي
لضمان امن حدودها
المشتركه
واتهمت النيتو بمد اوكرانيا بالمزيد من
السلاح في محاوله
لاستمرار هذه الحرب الدائره في اوكرانيا
وطبعا هناك اشارات واضحه على ان كل شيء
بات جاهزا من اجل تنفيذ هذا الاتفاق الذي
تم التوقيع عليها اليوم شيقو قال بان
بلاده زودت مينز بصواريخ اسكندر وقامت
باعاده تجهيز طائرات من طراز اخوي اضافه
الى خضوع الجيش البيلاروسي للتدريبات
اللازمه بهذا الخصوص في مراكز التدريب
الروسيه طبعا كل هذه التحركات تاتي كما
تقول روسي على التحركات الغربيه على
تحركات النيتو بالدرجه الاولى وهناك نذر
تصعيد في الحقيقه رغم ان هذا الاجتماع
الذي اعلن من خلاله اليوم على هذه
الاجراءات هو اللي وزراء دفاع دول معاهده
الامن الجماعي التي تضم ايضا دول اخرى في
المنطقه الى ان التركيز كل التركيز كان
على الوضع في اوكرانيا في خضم طبعا
اتهامات روسيا ايضا للجانب الاوكراني بانه
يحاول نقل المعركه بين قوسين الى داخل
الاراضي الروسيه بتنفيذه لمثل هذه
العمليات التي اعلن عنها جهاز الامن
الفيدراليه الروسي اليوم او ما حدث في بيل
جورد قبل يومين حينما اقتحمت او تسللت
مجموعه عسكريه اوكرانيه قالت روسيا انها
مجموعه تخريبيه الى داخل مقاطعه
هجوما هناك قبل ان تعلن وزاره الدفاع طبعا
عن تدبير هذه المجموعه
وملاحقه بعض فلولها الى داخل الاراضي
الاوكرانيه اذا يمكن وضع كل ما يجري الان
في اطار تنسيق بين روسيا وبيلاروسيا قد
يعلن ايضا اليوم من خلال اللقاءات
الهامشيه التي
يعرفها
المنتدى الاقتصادي الاوراسي الذي يعرف
ايضا هنا في موسكو مشاركه الرئيس
البيلاروسي الى جانب قاده دول اخرى قريبه
من روسيا شكرا جزيلا لكم من